well hey everybody thanks for coming to
my talk I hope you're all sufficiently
caffeinated it's pretty late in the
afternoon yeah my name is Henry Hannah
Feld I'm a physics PhD student I took a
break from that this summer to do the
data science for social good fellowship
today I'll touch on that a little bit at
the end but mostly I'm going to talk
about a side project I did for fun that
does absolutely zero social good
whatsoever which is high frequency
trading in online video games so this
talk is about two things there are two
main points the first is it's a story
about making fake money in video games
on the internet and hopefully this will
be a somewhat entertaining story but I
imagine that's not a super broadly
applicable task for most of you so I'm
also hoping that this will be a nice
introduction to how some of these tools
in the Python data science stack kind of
fit together so in my experience there
are a lot of great tutorials and we had
some of these yesterday about how to use
all of these different pieces
individually how did learn pandas learn
Luigi learn scikit-learn but there
aren't a ton of kind of full pipeline
examples that walk you through using all
of them together and putting together a
full-on pipeline so what I'm trying to
do with this talk is using this kind of
simple toy example walk through how you
build a whole pipeline by putting these
different tools together so that's where
I'm that's why I'm trying to get this is
how we're gonna get there first I'm
going to give a little background on EVE
Online which is the video game that is
all built on top of and then next I'm
gonna walk through the the pipeline that
I built to do this high frequency
trading in this video game and then
finally at the very end I'll very
briefly touch on how you can take this
and move it beyond video games so first
off show of hands who has heard of EVE
Online before was a good audience for
this talk
as it does anyone play Eve anybody know
nobody wants to admit it that's what I'm
here for
so Eve for those of you who haven't
heard of it is an online multiplayer
video game that's based in space so you
get spaceships you fly them around you
shoot at stuff one reason it's famous is
there are these giant battles where
literal thousands of real people will
coordinate and work together at the same
time so it's really big and really
involved and there's all kinds of
interesting interesting emergent
gameplay but for the purposes of this
talk Eve is super interesting because it
has a functional market and what I mean
by that is all of the transactions all
of the like buying and selling items
that happen in this game happen between
two players in the game so normally in a
video game you know you if you need
something you go to the little shop you
pay your five gold coins and you get
your sword and the game just kind of
like creates that sword and gives it to
you in exchange for your gold coins in
EVE all of you nearly all of the items
are created by players in the game so
you can extract raw materials you can
set up some industry things where you
turn those raw materials into
commodities and to ships into whatever
and every time you're buying and selling
something you're buying from another
player or selling to another player so
that means all the prices in the game
are determined by actual market forces
and you see real market effects
happening so the plot I have here is
just like the historical market price
for one particular item the yellow dots
are like the average price the green
bars at the bottom are the volume of
items sold for every day in the last
three months or something and you can
see that the price bounces around all
over the place it's reacting to supply
and demand what this means is you can
sit in the middle of item trades in the
game and make money just by being a
middleman and for the rest of this talk
whenever I say make money you can just
replace fake internet money this isn't
making actual money it's just kind of an
exercise and learning to use these tools
but you can make money just by
participating in the market buying items
at a low price and selling them at a
high price so that's that's kind of what
I'm trying to do here but since I'm
using all of these Python data science
tools I need to have data to actually
work with and fortunately Eve has an API
that exposes all of this market data so
Eve is kind of a crazy video game yeah
but you can get you can get all that
market history that I showed in the
previous plot you can get the average
price the high price the low price the
volume the number of transactions for a
given day for I think like the last
three months at a time you can also get
the current market snapshot so you can
see a list of all the existing orders
like what people are buying for what
they're selling for what the volume of
items on the market is and finally you
can get a list of your characters
historical transactions so you can see
what you bought what you sold and how
much you paid for each time so given all
of that backstory what I'm trying to do
here is make a python-based machine
learning pipeline that consumes all of
that data and identifies item where
there's a good opportunity to do this
middleman trading just sit in the middle
and get space rich this is a good point
to give the caveat that I'm not actually
automating the interactions with the
client I'm not automating the putting in
of the buy and sell orders the the terms
of service for the Eve game say that you
can't automate your interactions with
the client you can't
this isn't like every 30 milliseconds
I'm updating orders in the client
because that's forbidden it'll get you
banned but what I am doing is
algorithmically figuring out what trades
I want to make so picking out the items
that I want to use so that's what I'm
trying to do and I'm gonna do that using
three pieces first I'm going to use
Luigi to
get all that data from the API then I'm
gonna plug it into pandas and turn the
raw stuff that I get down from the API
into something usable for kind of
algorithmic predictions and then I'll
use scikit-learn to actually do the
machine learning part this talk is not
it's not going to be a tutorial on how
to use these three libraries there's not
enough time there were good tutorials
yesterday there are a lot of good ones
online I'm just trying to kind of like
give an existing example use case of how
these might fit together and a couple
quirks that were particularly helpful
for this project
so first up getting the data with Luigi
I'm trying to get the market history so
the average price high price all that
stuff and also the current market orders
so what people are buying and selling it
for for every actively traded item in
the game there are about 2,500 items so
this comes out to about 5,000 API calls
and I want to do these 5,000 API calls
with parallelization so I don't have to
sit here forever waiting for 5,000
things to run in a row and I also want
to be able to automatically retry on
failure because you know it's an API
sometimes packets get lost sometimes my
internet connection is spotty and I
don't want to be doing all of my trading
analysis missing some chunks of data I
don't wanna I want this to be robust to
network failures and this is where Luigi
comes in super handy because pretty much
straight out of the box with Luigi you
get these features so I know I said this
isn't gonna be a tutorial but I am gonna
give like a five minute whirlwind tour
of Luigi because a lot of the rest of
this is built on top of Luigi the the
main idea in Luigi is this idea of a
task and in an abstract sense a Luigi
task is something that pulls in some
amount of data does something with it
and spit something out and in practice
that's implemented in this in a Python
class that subclasses
Luigi tasks and it has these three
methods that required that do each of
those three things so the require method
tells you what its gonna pull in the
output method tells you what is gonna
spit out and the run method is what it
how it actually does stuff how it turns
that input into its output so to give
like a brief example of each of those
three methods say I have three different
Luigi tasks a B and C and the requires
structure looks like this
so a requires B and C B requires
something else and C doesn't require
anything that gives me a dependency
graph over here that looks like this so
if I tell Luigi hey I really want to do
task a that's what I need to happen
right now Luigi is automatically going
to go through and check if B and C are
done and run them if they're not output
output is the next of these three
methods that just says what is this task
gonna spit out so that's you know
they're your text file in my case this
will be the results of an API call where
I get down some JSON or some XML or
something but it also serves a second
role which is the existence of a output
is how Luigi tells if a task is done or
not so when I go back to this requires
thing when I tell Luigi to run task a
and it checks if task B and text C are
done the way it does that is it just
says what does task B's output supposed
to be and does it exist or not and here
you can see we're already getting the
automatic retry on failure aspect of
Luigi so if I tell Louise you to run
task a and it goes back and says well I
need to do B and C so it tries to do B
and C but for some reason task C doesn't
work like the packets could drop my
computer catches on fire something bad
happens and C doesn't happen well it's
gonna go through one iteration and then
it's gonna go back and say all right I'm
all set to do task a right let me just
check and make sure it'll go back and
see yep B is fine but all of a sudden C
still doesn't exist so it'll go back and
redo C so we get this automatic
retry on failure business so that's the
output and then the run is just whatever
Python code you want to actually turn
your input into your output so in this
toy this simple example it's just
writing to an out file in my example
we'll be making an API call and then
writing that to a file but it can be all
kinds of things you can you can write to
a database you can write to s3 you can
write to there's a bunch of potential
outputs here okay so that was that was
my whirlwind tour of Luigi so now I'm
back to back to the eve trading and how
I'm gonna use it in the pipeline well
I'm gonna take each of these API
endpoints that I want to consume and
turn them into a Luigi task so I'll walk
through one example but the other one is
going to be exactly the same so I want
to get the market history for every item
so I'm gonna make this class get market
history which is a loo easy task and it
looks like this so there's there's a
couple main pieces the first is this
Luigi dot parameter business which I
skipped in the whirlwind tour but the
basic idea is that instead of writing an
init method where you set up class
attributes you just do them with this
Luigi parameter syntax and that gets you
some other nice advantages if you want
to do things with dates but I'm not
going to talk about it the next thing we
have is requires and that's empty to
call the API I don't need to consume
some existing text file so this task
doesn't depend on anything else the
output is just gonna be a flat text file
so call it history underscore and then
some type ID which identifies the item
that I'm trading and then the run method
which I just write some function
somewhere else that queries the API and
spits back some JSON or some XML so I
just did the result open up my output
that I've defined in this task write it
and I'm done so with these I don't know
two dozen lines of Python code I already
have all of these I can get the type of
the information for all kinds of
item types so the next step is to take
that task which gets the information for
a single item and use that to get the
information for all of the items and
this is where another Luigi abstraction
comes in handy which is rapper tasks so
these are just like the other tasks
except all they have is a set of
requirements this is basically a
checkpoint saying when I run this I want
you to run all of these other things
you're not going to do anything you're
just gonna make sure that these are all
done so you just fill up that requires
method with everything else that you
need it to have and in this case I just
loop through the type IDs of every item
that I care about in the game and say
give me the market history for that type
ID so that gives me a dependency graph
like this or I can tell Luigi run get
all market history and it will
automatically know that it needs to get
the market history for all these other
items and this is where the second
really handy feature of Luigi comes in
which is the super easy parallelization
when I invoke Luigi when I say run this
task up here get all market history I
can just add another argument that says
and use 20 workers and all of a sudden I
have 20 fold parallelization Luigi can
tell that each of these individual tasks
is independent it can run by itself so
all you have to do is say I want you to
parallelize this 20 ways or 30 ways or
50 ways or whatever and it'll do it for
you automatically out of the box so that
that's kind of all it takes to do this
API consumption for the market history
and you can do exactly the same thing
for the the market orders the current
market orders snapshot so we have one
for market history we have one for the
orders we can do another task down the
line that consumes all those text files
and spits them into a database and in
general this pattern exists for the rest
of the pipeline I won't make it explicit
but for each next step all I need to do
is write a little Luigi task that says
what am I trying to do and what was the
previous step in this and at the end of
the day I just tell Luigi to run the
very last task in that process and it'll
automatically work its way back through
run everything that needs to be run and
then spit out the answer at the very end
and this also gets us to the last
advantage of Luigi that I found super
helpful which is it is it makes it
really easy to pick things up if they
break in a bad way halfway through so
since a task is done if its output
exists if I'm running this and the
market history works fine but I had a
bug or something in my market orders one
and only half of this pipeline gets run
if I want to go back and you know fix
the bug and run the pipeline again
Luigi since the files from the market
history already exists it knows it
doesn't have to redo this and this is
much harder to do if you have just like
a flat script that runs all of these
things one at a time you don't get that
same easy just oh let me just fix that
typo run the thing again if you do it
with the other systems you have to rerun
the whole pipeline which can be
time-consuming all right so third of the
way through that was Luigi getting all
of the data from the API down into a
local database or for me so the next
step is turning the raw data that I got
from the API into something useful into
some-some per item statistics that I can
use to try to figure out what I want to
be trading and for that obviously the
tool is pandas so I'm again not going to
do like a big intro to pandas but a
couple of things that I found
particularly useful for this project and
this this part proceeds in three steps
so first I've scraped all that API data
I put it into a database now I want to
play around with it in pain is so I'm
going to pull it out of the database do
some stuff to it and then put it back
into the database and I did not know
this existed until not too long ago but
pandas has a read sequel table function
which is awesome you give it a database
connection thing whether from psycho PG
to or SQL alchemy or something and it'll
just take your table and give you back a
data frame this is super duper
convenient but it is not super duper
fast for
this project I'm only at maybe a couple
hundred thousand rows and if this
totally works fine for that but if you
start scaling up from that by an order
of magnitude or so then this starts to
get kind of slow so anyway I use this
read sequel table function I get all of
that raw data that I scrape from the API
into my data frame and next I want to
make some some per item features so I
want to know for a particular item type
what are all these different summary
statistics that I can use to identify
whether or not it might actually be good
to trade on the market so here as one
example I'll walk through how I'm
finding the margin on each item so what
is the difference between the highest
buy price and the lowest sell price like
what is my if I'm trying to be the
middleman how much middle is there so
this is what raw market order data looks
like I tell whether it's a buy order or
a sell order when it was issued what the
price is what the volume what the volume
entered is so like what did it start out
as how much is left
and finally the type ID and if I want to
figure out for example the margin this
is a really simple example but the point
of it being so simple is to show how
simple pandas makes it to do this kind
of thing all I need to do is separate
the buy and sell orders group by the
type ID and then compare the maximum
prices this this example is practically
trivial but that's the point with pandas
doing this is super duper easy so I have
all this data I pull it down I come up
with a bunch of things that I think
might help me identify which of these
items would be good to trade so for
example I just set the margin what about
like how much volume does it trade in a
day if the margin is really big but it
sells one or two then there's not a lot
of room right there versus if there's a
more modest margin
but it's being bought and sold all of
the time that's probably a better
candidate but what like what about
competition how many other buy orders
are there how many other sellers are
there are a lot of other people trying
to do the same thing for the
item or even even more complicated
things like how much does this price
bounce around during the week is it
really volatile is it really stable you
can do all kinds of features these are
just a couple examples and finally to
put it back in the database when you
know if there's another handy panda's
function - sequel which is exactly the
opposite you just tell the table name
spit it back and this comes with the
same caveat that it is SuperDuper
convenient but not SuperDuper fast okay
so we've got the data pulled it down we
twisted it around and put it into forms
that are useful on a per item level and
finally we want to actually do the
machine learning to identify the
promising items so I'm going to do this
with psyche and I'm gonna do it with a
supervised learning approach so I'm
gonna take all these features and come
up with some labels about what are and
what aren't good items to trade and to
do that I ran a little experiment where
I randomly picked some subset of the
items I put the same amount of fake
Internet money into each of those items
and then traded them for a week using
the same amount of like time playing the
game for each item and then at the end I
went back and looked at that third API
endpoint the one that shows you all of
your characters transactions and saw you
know for this particular item type I
bought this mini at this price I sold
this many of this price and figured out
how much profit I made on each different
item type so doing that I get a set of
labels for some of the different item
types you know this one may be some
number this one may be something else I
lost some money on this one
I combine that with all of the features
that I put together in pandas and as is
the usual trope the actual machine
learning part is like you know 1% of all
the code that went into this project I
just pull in scikit-learn and it's
really like three lines so that that's
basically the whole pipeline that's the
whole system
the next obvious question does it work
so the the target I set for myself was
trying to make 1 billion in fake
Internet dollars per month because Eve
requires a subscription so you have to
pay 20 bucks a month to play the game
but you can also pay for game time using
in-game currency so as an aside if
you've ever seen newspaper articles
where they talk about internet video
games space battle costs two hundred
thousand dollars that's where this
conversion comes from you see how much
how much money was lost in the game and
conferred that 220 dollars using the
game time so anyway I'm trying to make
more than 1 billion a month because that
way my videogame habit is
self-sustaining you might think yourself
this is an awful lot of work to put in
for $20 a month and you're not wrong but
it was fun work so yeah win-win so does
it work well this is the net worth
versus time of my character in the game
when I kicked it off I had it a little
over 2 billion and after about a month I
was up to a little over 4 billion so it
works I can continue to thanks I
appreciate your validation of of all
this effort so so yeah that's that's
basically the pipeline I built but
before I end I want to kind of touch a
little bit on how you can move this
beyond video games and trivial things
like this so I did spend the summer
doing the data science for social good
fellowship and there were a ton of super
diverse projects and problems that
people worked on there was the police
project that was the one I worked on and
you're ready to talk about it if you
went to the keynote earlier there was
one looking at infrastructure problems
in Syracuse predicting like water main
pipe breaks there's one doing
educational achievement there's one
doing emergency medical service
dispatching just an enormous diversity
of problems and different types of tasks
to do with data
and just about every single one of these
DSS G projects use these same the same
general framework of a lot of Luigi to
get the data a whole lot of pandas to do
interactive stuff and then some
scikit-learn at the end so this was a
very trivial hopefully entertaining but
in the end not very important use case
for this but these same tools can be
used in all kinds of different contexts
and in some impactful ways so that's
what I got thanks for your attention and
any questions it's definitely a fun a
fun substrate for a lot of further
experimentation I should mention that
the for this particular application the
machine learning and scikit-learn was a
little bit overkill the the features
that ended up being important were
absolutely the features you would expect
just like what's the margin what's the
volume what really was useful about this
was that it could scan every single item
and find like little local spikes so if
all of a sudden some big margin opens up
on one particular item this could find
that whereas if you're a person just
clicking through all the items you
wouldn't necessarily be able to find
that so the the real value in this was
the robust consumption of the API data
and the machine learning on top of it
was was fun but not the main value add I
think I saw another hand back there I
didn't want to pay for my video games
that that's a little glib I didn't want
to pay for the video games but I also
had heard about a lot of these tools and
like wanted wanted a fun way to learn
about how to use them in kind of a an
interesting context way way back no
comment any others the so Luigi doesn't
do the scheduling you have to kick it
off either manually or with cron or
something like that
the the way I do it is I just have a
cron thing that has it spit out what I
should be looking at each day I'm sorry
was there a second part that I've oh and
like the pandas analysis and stuff oh
yeah I should have done a better job of
making this clear but all of the
subsequent steps so the pandas part and
the scikit-learn part those are all so
wrapped up in Luigi tasks so and the
like the final writing out a sorted list
so I just tell it to kick off the whole
pipeline and it runs through all of that
I don't know it does all right so the
the second main abstraction in Luigi
that I didn't really talk about is this
idea of targets so all of the outputs
are going to be a Luigi target and there
are existing classes for a lot of
different targets so I use the local
file system target which is just a file
on the local file system and they have a
bunch of other targets for like remote
file system target s3 things like that I
didn't explore this a ton but the
database targets are not super or at
least to me we're not super
straightforward right off the bat so
there isn't a trivial way to say like
does did this successfully insert all
the things that I wanted to insert into
the database the kind of the janky
workaround I ended up using is for all
of my database tasks I would just write
a file that was like committed to
database not done and use that as my
local target to get that same
functionality but I think there do exist
within Luigi things for having database
targets I just didn't have a lot of
success working with them Oh
not if you want to keep your account
yeah it's a one-way conversion like you
can you can buy these gametime items
with real money and then sell them for
in-game currency but you can't do the
reverse the API the EVE API isn't far
enough to do that like the end point you
tell it a type ID and it just spits back
everything no or at least the best my
knowledge that's how the API works I
don't know about the like examining the
data that it's pulling in but Luigi does
have very nice date parsing and date
handling things so if you remember I
kind of glossed over that Luigi
parameter syntax instead of the init
method and the reason is it has its own
syntax is you can specify date
parameters and date range parameters and
that will do that will get you like a
lot of nice command-line automatic
parsing of date strings so if you have
tasks that are like daily reports or
weekly reports then you can do some nice
fancy stuff with these date parameters
and date range parameters that gets you
like in the same direction of your
question but I don't know about
examining the data itself it's not there
yet I'm willing to put it up there I
won't put up like the data that I used
to train it but once I clean it up and
make it look nice then I'll put it up
well if that's it I'll thank you for
your attention
you